new rainfall is in the forecast for
Texas threatening hundreds more homes
with devastating flooding several days
of rain of swollen rivers and lakes to
near record levels at least two people
are dead
mark Strassmann is in Kingsland Texas I
would say it probably came up five or
six feet in a matter of 15 minutes 15
minutes yeah so it was that fast and
Scott Turner's home here in Kingsland
Texas the rush of early morning flood
water caught his family completely
off-guard we got all the stuff out of my
wife's office I moved it into the house
and as soon as we got it into the house
then the house started flooding so we
didn't really have a chance to get
anything out and what was going through
mommy lucky you make you live in on the
water just know one thing your Matt had
just just thinking what you can get out
and you know at that point there was
nothing there was nothing we could do
his story echoes across Central Texas
where rising flood waters have become
increasingly dangerous rescue crews have
saved dozens of people including this
rescue we came across yesterday two men
in an SUV trapped in a ditch after they
tried to cross a flooded Road now
authorities are doing what they can to
limit the damage at Mansfield dam for
floodgates are open to drain water from
overflowing Lake Travis for more are
expected to open today the current water
level of Lake Travis is about 700 feet
which has already caused flooding in
dozens of homes if it rises another 14
feet the water will flow uncontrolled
from the dam submerging entire
communities back upstream Scott Turner
is just trying to pick up the pieces you
think you've seen the worst of it yes I
hope
fingers crossed yeah I don't think he
could get any worse the Turner's got a
half mile from the Llano River but it
was still too close you could see oh how
the water came up inside their house and
the water mark in this bookcase and now
most of their indoor furniture is
stacked outdoors very little of it
salvageable and there's more rain more
potential flooding in the forecast today
Gayle mark thank you